for one final time the sixes were on
official duty from the reaction of the
schoolchildren they were obviously still
the star attraction as they made their
way to their seats but with Prince
William and Kate next up the aisle all
eyes were on the Cambridge's and the
Sussex is it's up to you to decide if
you think this is awkward
Prince Edward took charge of the small
talk as the brothers kept their eyes on
their order of service usually the Queen
would be center of attention for the
first time we've seen the Sussex is with
their relatives was always going to
distract from the celebrations for her
Commonwealth family the past five days
have felt like their farewell tour with
no confirmation of how much time they're
going to spend in the UK in the future
there's no doubt the Sussex is have
attracted a new kind of crowd and that
is a loss to the royal family there is
also of course uncertainty about this
new path that Harry and Megan want to
take but in some ways the door has been
left open because in 12 months time
there will be a review to see how it's
all working out when they got engaged we
got the sense they were excited about
what they could achieve together but the
scrutiny has proved too much and Palace
life too stifling even the Queen with no
option but to agree they can step away
at the end of this month it's actually
swapping one type of press intrusion for
another type of press intrusion I think
it's not something you can do very
quickly Megan would do it much more
quickly than Prince Harry because she's
used to this and that's her going back
to home territory but for Harry he's got
an awful lot to learn he he's you know
he's a military man
[Music]
the Queen has said they are still very
much part of the family in just over two
years they fulfilled every aspect of
royal life now those official duties are
over in the end their life together had
to come first
Rhiannon Mills sky news at Westminster
Abbey